Michael Kirschning who moved to Britain from
Germany takes advantage of every sale and
special offer he can find.
He lives in Milton Keynes north-west of London.
He's afraid price rises and shortages will
be rampant post Brexit.
Kirschning is a "prepper" - someone who prepares.
"People who've got money don't care - they
can afford everything.
You can always get anything for money.
But the rest of us will suffer.
I think conditions will deteriorate radically
- I can see it coming."
Kirschning and many other preppers see a potential
disaster following a hard Brexit.
And the government's plans do nothing to calm
those fears.
Three thousand, 500 troops are to be on stand
by in case of a no-deal Brexit.
"The soldiers will be armed and sent to keep
order.
So at some point, they'll start shooting at
people.
And that'll be the end of the road."
"What do you mean?"
"Then they'll have a little civil war on their
hands."
Preppers are afraid nothing will work properly
- including customs processing at the port
of Dover, the island's busiest harbor.
"Currently, it takes a minute and a half to
get a lorry through.
But once Britain's out of the EU, it'll take
about four minutes.
They're projecting five-mile tailbacks within
24 hours, and within the first week, the traffic
jam will reach London."
The authorities are also anticipating long
traffic jams in the event of a hard Brexit.
Food deliveries will be hard hit.
Britain imports nearly half its food from
abroad, most of it from the European Union.
Experts predict that fresh produce, in particular,
could be in short supply.
"Certain foods, like chilled foods, that are
fresh foods, that only have four or five days
life, they have to move very quickly through
the supply chain.
Any kind of delay would mean they just won't
be available, there isn't any stockpiling
or strategy that will work."
At the weekly market in Milton Keynes, Michael
Kirschning expects there will be less products
on offer.
But he seems to be one of the few people here
who worry about it.
The majority in Milton Keynes voted for Brexit,
and most people here still seem convinced
Britain will get by just fine on its own.
"People will be foolish, and they will start
stockpiling, and that may cause a problem.
But I think it´s something that´s unnecessary.
Food shortages won't happen if people are
sensible and shop sensibly."
"I think we've got to get on and do it, we've
got to claim back our sovereignty, we can't
be ruled by Brussels any more."
Michael Kirschning isn't leaving anything
up to chance.
He picks up tips from other preppers on Facebook:
how to dry vegetables so they'll keep longer,
for instance.
Some are even buying camping supplies to be
ready in case of power outages.
"What I've got on my shelves here ought to
last two months.
I've got enough in my freezer to get me through
another three months.
So that's no problem."
Michael Kirschning thinks anyone who isn't
taking precautions is naive.
He's even got a plan B worked out.
If the worst comes to the worst, he can always
return to Germany - after almost thirty years
in Britain.